MARTIN OMANDER: Hi.
Welcome to Root Access, a show
on Google Developers Live
about startups.
My name is Martin Omander, and
I'm joined here today by Don
Dodge, Googler, longtime
investor, and start up
evangelist.
Don, today we're going to talk
about founders who say I have
a great idea but--
so I'm sure you've heard
this many times.
Founders who come and say, I
have a great idea but I don't
have any money.
What do you tell founders
who say that?
DON DODGE: Well, first of all
they're not founders.
If they just have an idea and
haven't founded a company,
then they're like the rest of us
who have lots of ideas but
haven't executed.
So to be a founder, you
have to take that idea
and execute on it.
You have to convince other
people to join you and build a
company and move forward.
So I get those emails every day
about, I have a great idea
about something.
And we're all consumers, so
consumer focused companies,
everyone has an idea for a
consumer or social app or a
mobile app.
Because we all have phones and
we all have mobile apps and we
all have ideas for
mobile apps.
But those are just ideas, and
they don't become interesting
until you've thought about it
further, convinced other
people to join you, convinced
investors to put money in.
So ideas are just ideas,
and they literally
are a dime a dozen.
MARTIN OMANDER: So another thing
early founders say is, I
have a great idea but I won't
tell you about it because I'm
afraid that you or somebody
else might steal it.
What do you say?
DON DODGE: Yeah, I
hear that too.
Less now than in the past.
But the reality is that if you
don't talk about your idea,
you're not going
to get advice.
You're not going to find
out if the idea is
reasonable or not.
So you need to talk about the
idea with early users,
potential customers, to get
their feedback to see if it's
something that they're
really interested in.
Quite often, we're delusional,
and we think an idea is great
because we're talking
to ourselves.
You need to talk to other people
to see if it's really
an idea that has legs.
You need to talk to people to
find your co-founders and get
them excited about the idea
and willing to join you.
You need to talk to potential
investors to see if there's
interest in this idea, talk to
potential customers or users
to see how they would use it.
So you need to be out there
talking about your idea.
The chances that someone
is going to steal
your idea are minimal.
In fact, I've rarely ever
seen that happen.
More often the case is that
people want to offer advice
and offer help.
Very few people or very few
companies are going to drop
what they're doing to
steal your idea.
That almost never happens.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
The couple of times I've seen
one company take on the
business model of another, it's
they're going after an
established business.
Not really a very early
stage start up.
DON DODGE: That's right.
And big companies have 100 other
priorities, and they
have established products and
road maps, and they have a
hundred things that they
want to do on that
product road map.
They are likely not interested
in implementing an idea that's
not already in their road
map, so highly unlikely.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
OK, very good.
So let's dig into that a little
bit because a lot of
founders have great ideas but
they don't want to hire a
bunch of developers and spend
a lot of money and time
validating the idea.
You spoke some about how can
they validate the idea early
on, soon, and with
minimal invest?
DON DODGE: Yeah, well, that's
the beauty of today.
You can start a company
for almost no money.
Because if you can code, if you
can build, then you can
start a company.
Validation comes
in many forms.
So if you were to take your
idea to some potential
co-founders and they're willing
to drop what they're
doing and come join you to build
this product, that's
validation that this is
an idea that has legs.
If you're able to talk to
advisors who have industry
knowledge, and they know the
industry and they agree, this
is an interesting idea, and
they're willing to help you as
an advisor, that's validation.
If you talk to users and early
potential customers, they'll
give you advice and help improve
the idea, that's
validation that it's
something good.
And then, early investors.
Investors are looking
for that validation.
They're looking to see that
there are other people who
will quit their jobs to come do
what you're talking about.
They're looking for advisers as
validation, that yes, they
have domain experience, they
understand this and they're
willing to get involved.
Early use cases from customers
or users, all of those things
create validation in the minds
of investors so that they're
willing to put their money in.
MARTIN OMANDER: Because they
won't spend as much time as
the investor or the co-founder
understanding the idea, so it
helps them to see that the
adviser or the co-founder
thinks it's a good idea.
DON DODGE: Exactly.
So investors are looking
for validation from
all of those areas.
And if it's missing, if it's too
early, and you don't have
co-founders, or you don't have
early users, or you don't have
advisers, then the investor is
going to be a little nervous.
Unless they know you very, very
well, they're not going
to write a check.
Or unless they know this
business and have had
experience in it, they're not
going to write a check.
So they're looking for
that validate.
MARTIN OMANDER: So get away from
your desk, get out there,
sounds like the way to do it.
DON DODGE: Absolutely.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
Thank you, Don.
That's all for today.
If you have comments or
questions, please leave them
under the YouTube video in the
comments, and we'll try to get
back to them in future
episodes.
Thanks for joining us
and see you at the
same time next week.
Bye.